[Music]
[Applause]
all right uh Carson Palmer former NFL
quarterback won the Heisman at USC
loaned that Heisman to us for uh quite
some time and then we send it back
um he joins us now he is part of the
plant-based wellness program the company
called level select and we enjoyed
talking to him and promoting this for a
while and it's a level select OTC that's
a new plant-based pain relief brand and
uh they've been doing this for a long
long time did you play against Dion
Carson I did I actually played against
Dion his on his comeback tour when he
played for Baltimore uh with Ray Lewis
and Ed Reed and that that defense that
they had in Baltimore at the very very
end I think it was obviously Dion's last
year
um so I got a chance to play play
against him at the end I think he was
wearing number 39 or number 49 or
something really ugly out there but he
was still Dion 37 yeah 37 37 that's what
it was how good was that defense
foreign
a couple years before that defense was
really really good I mean peloti NADA in
the middle was a nose guard that was
really tough to move and
um obviously Ray Lewis Bart Scott Ed
Reed Chris McAllister I mean you go on
and on down the list that was a really
really talented group all right before
you came on I said that you had a
surprise pick as your number one
quarterback let me go around the room
with the dance and then we'll get to uh
Carson's pick as his number one
quarterback in the NFL Todd
O'Connor Joe burrow all right Marvin
Justin Herbert all right Paulie it can't
be any of those three because those
aren't surprises Trevor Lawrence all
right Carson the number one quarterback
is who
Conor was right I like Joe burrow
yeah okay I I was playing a game where
we got to pick our our what quarterback
you want what's your your top receiver
at X your top receiver at Z tight end
and it was funny because I ended up with
Joe burrow Justin Jefferson uh
jamarche so all three LSU guys and then
Travis Kelsey at tight end so LSU's been
pumping them out and that program has
gotten really really good okay but why
burrow over Patrick Mahomes
uh it's obviously a a fist fight when
you bring that one up
um but I just he's younger I'll take the
younger quarterback if I'm if I'm gonna
build a program around a guy he's got a
little less wear and tear he's a little
bit younger and he's a lot cheaper right
now because he's still on his rookie
deal as opposed to Patrick Mahomes who's
the second or third highest paid highest
paid player in the league
what do you think is going to happen
with burrow and Justin Herbert as far as
their contracts and and if you're their
agents what are you basing it off of
like where do you start that contract
negotiation
just whoever signs the next deal
um you know it's it's it's a moving
Target every year the next guy that gets
paid it's the highest paid guy so it
just seems like where we're at right now
Joe Burrows the next guy to get paid
they've been talking about a contract
extension for months now
um so it seems like he's about to set
the bar a little bit higher than whoever
the last guy is that just okay but Jalen
hurts got paid is Joe burrow does he
start there with his negotiations of
Jalen hurts or does he say I want Kyler
Murray money
or does somebody get Squirrely and say I
want DeSean Watson money
no he just needs he needs more money
than Jalen hurts just got he did the
same thing Jalen hurts did except for
he's done it for one more year you know
Jalen hurts just went to the Super Bowl
and lost Joe burrow the prior year just
went to the Super Bowl and lost so the
way these contracts work is the next guy
that gets paid gets paid a little bit
more so he should just be a couple
hundred thousand dollars more per year
than Jalen hurts got and probably the
same duration probably another five-year
contract is Jalen hurts a great
quarterback or in a great situation
that's what the world's about to find
out I mean they just paid him they just
paid him a bunch of money they got to
get rid of a couple guys it might be a
pass rusher it might be a receiver uh it
might be a backup left tackle it's a
swing tackle that can play left and
right but as soon as you go from having
a rookie quarterback contract to a real
vet contract at some point you got to
start cutting trimming some fat on that
roster and get that roster and that
salary cap down a bit so that that's
what we're about to start seeing in
Philly is they got to start giving up
some of these great players they've had
on the offense and defensive side of the
ball would you rather have a great
tackle or a great wide receiver
a great tackle no doubt I mean at the
end of the day when you're a quarterback
you got to be able to step into throws
and you got to be able to step in the
throws to deliver the ball accurately
down the field and it really doesn't
matter I mean you can have a top two or
three receiver in the game
um you can have kind of a bottom two or
three receiver in the game if you have a
great offensive line and they can block
for four and a half seconds because at
the end of the day if you can block for
four and a half seconds you don't need
to pay your receivers 20 million bucks a
year those guys can get open but you
can't get the ball to them if you can't
step into throws so at the end of the
day I'd rather have the offensive line
over the super talented receiver
former number one overall pick Carson
Palmer joining us on the program your
thoughts the Jets finally get Aaron
Rodgers let's start there what would
your expectation level be as a Jets fan
well you still gotta get past Buffalo
and you still got to get past Miami I
mean I just don't think it was a
situation where Aaron was going to a
superstar team I mean at the end of the
day when you look at those two rosters
and you take and you when you compare
side by side
the Green Bay Packers roster and the New
York Jets roster and you take Aaron
Rodgers out of the equation and you just
say what's the next Bex player the next
best player is Aaron Jones the running
back for the Green Bay Packers and so
when you start really going through this
this roster one by one there might be a
better receiver here or there in New
York but I think the offensive Line's
better in Green Bay I think Aaron Jones
is a massive impact game-breaking player
in Green Bay the defense is a little
better in in New York maybe but Quinn
and Williams is now looking for a new
contract possibly so maybe he gets
traded the Big D tackle from Alabama
it's a high pick
um you know so you lose Quinn and
Williams if if he gets traded or or
maybe you know he's talking about maybe
a little bit of a hold out you got that
dude you know you got to deal with that
so wait so you I think the Packers
roster is as talented as the Jets and
maybe more talented
uh I I don't I think it's a a lateral
move I don't think it's drastically that
much better where I'm sitting there
going air you know if I'm Aaron I gotta
get to I got to get to New York the
roster's so good I think the rosters are
really similar I I just don't think
there's a drastic enough difference that
he's going from you know a b roster in
Green Bay to an A-Plus roster in New
York I just don't see that that great of
a talent increase in New York I think
it's a lateral move and you got to go
play in that division you're leaving the
NFC North where you really only have to
worry about Minnesota and they're kind
of hot and cold and hit and miss now
you're going to the that AFC you got you
got Josh Allen and buffalo you got Miami
who Miami can beat anybody on any given
day that's a really talented roster so I
just think that the division got a
little bit tougher overall the
conference you're now in the AFC it's
chocked full of great quarterbacks you
know I just I think it was kind of a
lateral move to go to a much much bigger
Market I wondered about this I wondered
about this for a while if you were the
Jets
does it make more sense to give up two
first-round picks to get Lamar Jackson
who's younger
and I'm gonna have to pay him a lot of
money just like I am Aaron Rodgers what
so would that make more sense for the
Jets to go after Lamar Jackson than a 39
year old Aaron Rodgers
yes if Lamar Jackson didn't have a big
asterisk around his name when it comes
to injuries at the end of the day the
one of the greatest abilities is
durability at the quarterback position
and availability if you're available to
be on the field for your team the the
odds go up that you win Lamar's that's a
big question mark around his name right
now is is the last two seasons he had
the knee this last year and couldn't
quite get it going again uh he had
injuries the year before so no doubt
he's younger he's explosive he's got all
the talent in the world but there's just
enough worry about these injuries that
Aaron might be the right play for the
Jets at this moment
how many quarterbacks
not will go in the first round how many
quarterbacks should go in the first
round like a first round grade
I think I think Bryce goes number one
and there's questions around him he is
not a very big human being at the end of
the day
he's he's all of 510 and I think you
know just over 200 pounds 511 200 pounds
I mean that that is not a big specimen
but he's got to go number one and I
really think he will outside of that
there's a again a bunch of question
marks will Levis there's a bunch of
question marks Richardson
um you know CJ there's guys that they're
gonna get somebody's gonna get over
drafted somebody's gonna draft probably
CJ at number two or three and probably
will love us in the top five and then
Richardson the top ten I think when we
look back on this draft there were a
couple quarterbacks that were worthy of
taking a chance on but not in the top
five picks I think if if you got a
chance to draft Richardson at like 18 or
22 you'd feel really good about it
because there is so much upside but
before that upside is reached there is
so much development that needs to happen
in his game so I just think so you know
as quarterbacks always do they're going
to get over drafted Bryce is probably
going to go number one and there's a
couple other guys that'll be in the top
five that when they look back they would
have felt a lot better drafting those
guys at 15 or 19 or 23 and so on what
was your uh rookie contract
my rookie contract was man back in the
day it was I think it was like seven
years long
um it was a seven year maybe 50 million
dollar deal I don't remember
did it change you at all
yeah drastically instantly
I went from I went from
um living in a crappy uh dorm uh just
outside of USC off the USC campus with
way too many roommates and too few of
bedrooms and a couple hundred bucks in
my name to a lot more than that but did
it change your person you know we talked
to Ryan Leaf yesterday and he said you
know I didn't handle the money well and
and it changed me and then I I thought I
was better than people
I I never have felt like that
um it it changed what I was able to do
instantly but I just I always kind of
had that chip on my shoulder like
you know I've got to earn it I've got to
show them that they made the right
decision and I always kind of had that
driving me and and that force behind me
wanting me to continue to work wanting
me and and then also you know you get
that question right away you don't want
to be the guy that got changed you don't
want to be the guy that had the response
that Ryan Leaf had so I always also had
that in the back of my mind where I
think you know I
you know from a mental standpoint from
what I was trying to do as as a player
and as a teammate I think I was just
driven to to continue to work
prove to people that it didn't change me
and and didn't change the outcome of the
person that I was but just continue to
work and get better at the game and and
be a better teammate what car did you
buy
uh well my baby I had a I had a 87
Cadillac Fleetwood that I got in college
for forty two hundred dollars and I was
taking that with me
um to Cincinnati and then I got hit by a
drunk driver on the 110 and he totaled
my my Fleetwood my baby and then I moved
to Cincinnati and I started a
relationship with Jeff Wyler Chevrolet
and they hooked me up with a Chevy
Avalanche
for free I got to drive a ship you
remember the old school Chevy Avalanche
uh a big truck
big truck no longer in production they
didn't make it uh I think I was the only
person that actually liked that truck
and that's why Chevy discontinued it
years later did you ever try to replace
the Cadillac with another Cadillac
no no I uh I mean that was my baby it
was a rolling sofa bed it was champagne
Brown
and it had a max speed of like 52 miles
an hour which doesn't work great in La
which is probably why I got hit in
downtown L.A by a drunk driver because I
was going too too slow on the freeway
did you get hurt at all in that accident
no I uh we're actually getting ready to
play Kansas State I think like the next
day or the following day but I remember
I was stuck on the 110
a a car was coming horizontally across
the highway and that was the drunk
driver that hit me
I smashed into him couple other cars
smashed behind me and I was getting
ready to play Kansas State in like two
you know maybe two or three days and
there's cars whizzing By Me Nobody stops
in L.A there's a middle you know a car
crash in the middle of the road and cars
are swerving around us going 70. and
just just no you know no hope and stuck
in the middle of the freeway we found a
way to get out of the car and got to the
side
um and I'm still here to speak about it
Dan
good to talk to you as always and uh
have fun with the draft
thanks Dan you too that's Carson Palmer
former number one overall pick Iceman
Trophy winner and uh he uh is working
with level select OTC those products
maintain a healthy and active lifestyle
always good to talk to him